if anyone knows what this shirt means I
love you the pack is a new horror film
the open and limited release it's also
on Amazon for rental which is where I
watched it it's about these two sisters
and they hate their mother they hated
their childhood her mother treated her
poorly growing up they go to her house
because she's passed away and they're
going to go to her funeral the one
sister gets there first though and has a
night alone in the house she starts
hearing things seeing things she starts
investigating then we cut to when the
next sister gets there the next morning
and there's nobody there there's just
random things spread throughout the
house that looked like some kind of star
will happen she starts hearing stuff in
the house weird things are happening
things are moving sounds are being made
she doesn't understand what's going on
so she starts to investigate what
happened to her sister and what's
causing this strange disturbance and our
mystery begins hi babies can you see
mommy can you see me now baby now as you
guys know I love scary movies but I also
hate the way that they have been treated
so lately in cinema cabin in the woods
was a great example of what should be
going on in horror movies and it just
makes fun of all the cliches that horror
films provide and it heard a lot of
things about this movie going into it a
few my pals saw it said it was really
suspenseful really scary a good horror
movie and then I saw a lot of comments
and reviews from people like on IMDB
just writing worst movie ever like in
all caps and I should just listen to my
friends in the first place because this
was a really clever horror movie and it
wasn't just the horror movie that you
walk into it and there's blood and guts
and nudity and everything that they try
to throw at a lot of horror movies
nowadays to mask the fact that the movie
actually sucks this was a quiet movie
with a lot of tension built up by really
good directions the director did a
really good job of using pans and zooms
just slowly coming in on whatever the
object is you're supposed to be afraid
of and you're like oh just whatever is
about to happen just happen already
please
I'm really worried about your coal hey
Nicole Nicole really good use of tension
in this movie I was very impressed this
is a really creepy movie it's actually
one of the more suspenseful movies I've
seen since insidious which did freak me
out a lot actually one of the things I
really liked that the director did was
that he didn't let the tension fade away
by using countless jump scares because
what jump scares do really is let the
tension that that scene was created let
that evaporate a good director who's
making a scary movie wants to keep the
suspense in tension all the way through
you don't want to have it all released
you know in various corny jump scares
like somebody put a hand on someone's
shoulder or you turn around and there's
a face or just you know just stupid jump
scares like a cat even though there are
a few jump scares in this move either
place at just the right points the
director did a really good job of
keeping tension really built throughout
a scene you keep thinking that something
is about to happen and sometimes nothing
happens and the scene just ends and you
get to the next one you're like wow so
the tension is still there it's in the
air and that's how you make a good
suspense movie you keep the tension
going through scene to scene to scene
without letting it all just release in
some corny jumpscare like a bird flying
at you like there were some times this
movie where like a character would be
looking through like a tiny peephole in
a wall or something whenever that
happens in the movie you're always
expecting somebody just jump out and go
and I kept expecting stuff like that to
happen but it didn't the director found
really clever ways to continue the scene
this is not what I thought because I
really honestly I've watched like a lot
of horror movies I don't review all the
ones I see I get a lot of stuff from
rental places and everything and I'm
used to the corny horror cliches that
are so prevalent in films today and this
movie didn't do too many of them the
acting was pretty good in the movie - I
liked the lead actress and one of the
things I liked was it kind of pulled of
psycho where it introduced you to an
actress and like okay this is who were
going with but then no actually we're
following this girl okay
I call that a psycho I don't know if
anyone
but I like the LIA grow up thought she
was talented you did a good job in the
movie now one of the things about this
movie is that it does have some cliches
in regards to the story noises at night
and weird creepy photos that maybe are a
clue to something you know we've seen
this before in movies like the ring but
the fact is whenever a writer or
director in this case the same person
wrote and directed this movie Nicholas
McCarthy can take a story that does feel
cliched and does have some of the horror
movie tropes but make it in a way and
present the material in a new way or a
way that is not cliched then I love that
because it's like yes I can take a story
that you might read and sit down and say
yeah that was interesting but I've seen
that a thousand times like I like a
director you can actually sit down and
say okay this story yeah this is kind of
familiar but I'm going to make it in a
way that's different I'm going to show
that I have passion for this material
and this direct did a really good job
with that I know I'm talking about the
director a lot that was the thing I was
most impressed with this movie was the
direction this is one of those movies I
want to and you to come when I go to
IMDB and like see what people are saying
and yes this movie is kind of ambiguous
and it does leave a few questions but if
you honestly pay attention during this
movie and if you actually think when
you're watching this movie I know most
people who pop in a horror movie don't
want to think they just want to be
bombarded with violence and sex and
stuff that doesn't really matter if you
watch this movie you're going to have to
pay attention and if you're bothered by
sometimes things being slightly
ambiguous or not entirely explained you
might not enjoy that in this movie I
like when a filmmaker is able to do that
in a way that doesn't feel lazy like he
just when I can't
dabbe whatever just end the pack scared
me it did I was very suspense buy a lot
of scenes in this movie and there were
times when I was like oh wait I don't
know if I want to look right now it was
actually a very intense well-done horror
movie I enjoyed the pack very much it
does have some cliches it does have a
few plot points that seem familiar and
it's not like a movie that you're going
to leave and just be like wow what an
experience that was it's just a
surprisingly good horror film a little
film and I think if you can find it on
Amazon or if it's playing in a theater
near you you should check it out I'm
going to give the packed a B+
and as always guys if you like this
review you can subscribe to my channel
and get stuck mine eyes